[Music]
morning Millennials welcome back to the
morning toast happy Monday it's feeling
you know not that Monday II today cuz
it's bright out I'm not definitely hell
it's right out the Super Bowl was last
night so everyone's in high spirits
except for San Francisco we're sorry to
tell you it just wasn't your time and as
predicted as predicted and you probably
should have placed bets based on what we
said on Friday if you were smart let us
know if you did but we could have told
you you know the outcome of last night's
game yeah and you know what I just have
a little note to whoever runs a Super
Bowl I feel like starting it at 6
o'clock is incredibly late like I just
don't feel like I should have gotten
home at 10:30 football's like a day
thing you know Thanksgiving football
starts at like noon I feel like it
should really be a daytime activity I
guess if you live in the West Coast it
was a daytime activity but it just seems
unfair I don't know I feel like it's
it's Sunday night it's me that it's the
echo beats like the Oscars you know oh
yes Sunday's not whoa
Sunday afternoon I know but football
just seems like a daytime thing you know
I liked everything about it I have no
complaints I liked the spread Olivia put
together quite a feast for us and I just
have to say I don't think I've eaten
that much in a really long time in one
sitting
me neither I really ate so much like so
much of everything it was actually such
a good time like I don't know how your
evenings were but ours was really
fabulous like that family was all
together we were laughing and laughing
talking we were tic-tac and we were
dancing we were even enjoying the game
too like we just Astin it had a really
nice Superbowl Sunday yeah and you know
the hard thing about the Superbowl is
like when you go to the bathroom cuz
like the game is good and then like when
the event commercials like that's when
you pee normally but that's when the
commercials were they were really
premium he during the game yeah of
course it's a lot of the same it was a
lot of the same it was really quite
there's no other word Jackie fabulous it
was quite super super it was it was
really the Super Bowl and I feel like it
was a good matchup because it's like two
teams who seemed kind of decent like I'm
there each other's levels yeah you know
that's the vibe I was getting like they
haven't been in the Super Bowl in a
while like it's not like the Patriots
versus the usual when I protect when I
projected sorry that the Kansas City
Chiefs are gonna win nobody told me
about Garoppolo and that might have
swayed me because whoa yeah no he's he's
smoking hot but um I already made my
and we said what I said so I couldn't
take it back I'm glad I didn't I'm so
glad I never get involved in like sports
really because I'm obviously joking
about that it's not your time even
though turned out I was right but I was
making jokes on my Instagram like I was
getting like death threats like people
in sports you think the toasters are not
no no sports fans are nuts no we we know
that also like it really was Kansas
City's time they like they hadn't won in
50 years I mean I didn't even know the
story and family invented the Super Bowl
I didn't even know the whole story look
about Andy Reid who's like the most you
know he's won the most games that coach
but he's never won a Super Bowl oh I
didn't even know that I think he's been
to the most Super Bowls and lost like he
has some crazy statistic well it really
was his time yeah it was Travis Kelsie's
time it was the time of the guy Williams
who just placed the ball over the line
like there was the most he I know that
like MVP goes to the quarterback and
Patrick mahomes did what he did and he
was he was fabulous but that guy who had
the foresight she just put place the
ball before he fell oh no buddy buddy I
thought that was brilliant stuff you
left early and we actually had a heavy
conversation about that guy cuz he was
also the guy who then scored the next
touchdown like from all the way down
appeals saying he should be MVP and it's
like it's so obvious that the
quarterback usually gets MVP but like I
think there should be like two awards
the quarterback gets an award because
the quarterback is arguably one of the
most important members of the team but
there should be like you know I ran the
most and scored the most touchdowns
award ya know like I don't know if there
should be two but I feel like it's
obvious at the quarterback the MVP so
like let's give the MVP to the person
who was the most valuable yeah and also
like how do you win a game you score
points who scores points not the
quarterback yeah unless like they're
right in right where right like you know
it's always fun light on their feet to
me their way into the end you know it
was quite exciting and I feel like I the
more I watch football like I definitely
understand more but I will never
understand the downs the down first down
fourth down is 7 to 10 there's two
clocks and it's just it's anxiety and
then there's lines on the field blue and
yellow but they're not really on the
field that thing I don't get players
can't see them so how the [ __ ] are they
do I are supposed to go and so why why
do we care
no we it's like it's a cheat for us so
we know where they need to go but if the
players can't see them like how do they
know where they gotta go it's incredibly
confusing it is but overall they run a
tight ship
it was star-studded it was star-studded
I love that it was in Miami I do feel
like it made it
extra fabulous agreed and I just want to
need to talk about the halftime show
yeah of course of course let's see what
we literally just joke to do let me just
jump right into the head story we
thought we would recap it first
okay you guys the halftime show was
absolutely fabulous one of the best I've
seen in my lifetime I mean it's I can't
tell if it was so good because it was so
good or because we're coming off the
maroon 5 halftime show you know what I
think it's like a year in between each
eye each one really stands on its own
and when before yesterday I didn't
realize that j.lo and Shakira were
co-headlining I thought it was JLo show
and Shakira was being featured just like
it was maroon 5 show and Travis Scott
was featured just like everyone else
does and like I'm kind of bummed for
Jayla like JLo did not need to share
that stage and everything was amazing
Shakira
she did a great job but JLo was
everything and all it needed was even
more JLo I totally like it just wasn't
after you know she was so incredible she
was so strong she's such an athlete like
up the singing the dancing the hair it
was just so fabulous I couldn't agree
more and I've been like nervous to say
my feelings because I don't want to
slide Shakira in any way it was a great
performance and honestly if JLo hadn't
performed after her we would have
thought it was the best performance of
the night but like JLo took it to a
whole other level with the dancing and
the singing and I have something
controversial to say because we have
said on the show many times that gialos
like she's a triple threat but she's not
that great of a singer and she usually
lip sings and I'm very hard on people
and I always am oh and every award show
every like televised musical event I'm
always very like specific and I watch
very carefully about the singing and I
am 100% sure that JLo did not lip-sync
and Shakira did which was shocking I
thought it would have been the opposite
I heard people saying the opposite I
don't think anything is for sure I don't
like that's what I thought when I
watched it too but I have no clue and
I'm not gonna say that attacked honestly
for all I know they both could have been
lip-synching well it's the first
telltale sign of lip-syncing is like
when somebody's track sounds just like
their iTunes like nobody sounds exactly
on Spotify as they do in a live
performance even if you're the best
singer in the world like there's
different elements yeah and so Shakira's
just really sounded like a playback of a
CD
whereas JLo when she Carrie did that a
little ad thing people her mic was on
she was like come on Miami like but if
your mic is on in your lip-syncing like
you can't lip-sync without actually
singing like usually your mic is off you
know I'm confused now that's interesting
and I'm not gonna I'm not gonna say one
word to the other but I will say that
regardless of whether and
they were lip-synching I do not give a
[ __ ] whatever you need to put on the
most incredible performance of all time
to 100 million people I do what you have
to do to make sure it's a showstopper
lip-sync if you if need be
I thought JLo was just spectacular
between she's all the elements of her
career most recently the hustlers poll
which was just fabulous and a really
added bonus for us viewers at home too
she included her daughter who by the way
can sing question mark it was
spectacular and I got chills when all
the kids came out with their American
flag things and then the daughter saying
and then JLo had her Puerto Rican and
American flag which I just thought was
like a great moment for Puerto Ricans
like I just I can imagine like if I was
a Latin American and JLo and Shakira I
just rocked the stage I'd be felony and
JBAB
right I forgot about the features and
Demi Lovato oh right
it was just such an incredible it was
everything like that we care about on
our side of the entertainment side was
just done to a tee yeah just like
conceptually no not conceptually when
you take a step back and you see that
like maroon 5 was given the prestige of
headlining it by themselves when
honestly like JLo and Shakira separately
okay I could have done it alone and are
arguably bigger and more iconic than
maroon 5 like that just is upsetting and
you you have to think it's only because
they're women I don't know I don't
understand the choice like and if I were
JLo I'd be pissed but I think she
handled it just like a she's a woman who
supports him in and heard Shakira seemed
to really be getting along but I think
we could have had literally Shakira this
year in JLo next year and there would
have been no question from anyone
whether or not they deserved it's like
putting them together just seems weird
yeah and no one was talking about it
before cuz I didn't even realize oh
there was a New York Post article that
came out I think on Friday that was like
JLo need not be sharing the stage with
but she care person she Karen need not
be sharing the stage either like she
cares a global artist I don't want to
disrespect Shakira in her own regard
like she really is so accomplished and
she's a global superstar and she she
brought like a whole other audience to
the Superbowl because she is so global
but it just felt like so much when like
it was literally to halftime shows yeah
well I guess the more the merrier and I
as a consumer enjoyed it michio it was
so I'm not gonna complain it really was
fabulous except for the decision to open
with she-wolf that's just gonna be a no
from me dog that's just like the worst
[ __ ] song ever and it's like and but
we bounce back like it didn't bother me
it did I got that song it's [ __ ]
trash it was trash when it came out it
was trash mean she performed it last
night
and
I just I can't say chance but that's the
only negative thing I'm gonna say
whatever where and I love the
stripped-down version of let's get loud
even though I was like really looking
forward to like its game the whole night
we were ready for let's get loud because
that's just the bar mitts a song like
that really changed my life and I I'm
gonna say something controversial I
think it's J Lo's best song and the
moonlight beat but really let's get loud
oh and I just want to say justice for
pitbull like he deserved to be on that
stage heist night there was an emptiness
in the crowd I can feel it mr. 305 and
it was in my book right and so I just
feel like that was intentional it seems
like they were really trying to leave
him out right and I just like I want to
say dresses for pitbull also something
strange I think about Shakira set was
that she sang a song that wasn't hers it
was that cardi B song oh yeah
and that's when I thought that Jayla was
gonna come out and they were gonna
switch but she just and like had a
random song in her set that wasn't hers
maybe she wrote it I don't know I don't
know but if it's a good song and it's
good entertainment value I ain't
complainin yeah and what's that other
JLo song that's so good that's old do my
B phone the nice doggy can get one no
not that one the one I'm still I'm still
Jenny the Alexa next you know which one
no you're giving me nothing
there's the other one that's similar the
whites get loud that's like can't fight
the moonlight beat in the dark you
surrender your heart is that from Selena
I don't know it's just around the same
time here yeah yeah that's a great song
that's a great song and also she paid
homage to her American Idol days you
know gotta get on the floor which
pitbull is on thanks to Y it was really
like a very intentional leave yeah
exclusion pitbulls absence was blinding
it was so keenly felt that I hope he's
okay and that he wasn't included in the
weekend at all and interesting we were
speaking about this and you sent me a
follow-up article from Forbes is that
the Pepsi halftime show whoever performs
does not get paid yeah which is weird
because it's sponsored like you think
that they would get paid I don't like
how do you put a price in an artist
would be comparing each other like how
much I got paid versus how much I got
paid and it's like you have the biggest
stage in the world your music is gonna
be streamed for days because old songs
are gonna resurface you can't put a
price on that
and also JLo was in Miami the entire
week like doing sponsorships for
literally every one Hard Rock Hotel like
she's she's fine art and I just feel
like up until this point in my life I
just didn't appreciate how hard that she
worked yeah
and I'm from now going forward like I'm
so appreciative to have JLo in my life I
feel like I was appreciative of
everything JLo offers except her voice
and I feel like I really my heart and
mind was changed every everything was
changed she ended hair we have to give a
major shout-out to former guest on the
show Chris Appleton who was there on the
field with her touching her up seconds
before she went onstage
it was the luminous vivacious sexy loved
it I loved it
it was just it was all so good I don't
know what else to say outfits were great
it's just it was a great moment for
women it was it's like a limb it's like
yeah the woman's headlining like she has
to share with another woman totally it's
like when I said when Andy and when
Caitlyn was the Bachelorette and they
also had Brittany almost calling that a
great moment for women and so you can
look at it like either way glass
half-full glass half-empty I don't know
which ones optimistic and which ones
pessimistic but I'm just saying like
let's me not forget I just also need to
have like a moment of silence for a
Shakira's ABS like that was truly unfair
it was actually really rude of her to be
up there like that like no one litter
shoving tacos and doughnuts in my mouth
like I didn't I couldn't even breathe
like I actually it's like I'm betting my
pants and I was wearing leggings and
she's up there just like her hips they
truly they don't lie it was a very
honest show yes because the hips weren't
lying yeah and I kind of really
personally relate to Shakira because as
you know a few years ago she was
indicted for tax evasion and I just
totally understand and respect that like
I that's why I mean Michael situation
I've like this kindred spirit because
I'm one second away from evading my
taxes I did I forgot we reported that
story but I forgot it until now yeah
honestly okay let's talk about
commercials
oh yeah well we're some of your face I
have to just give like you know when I
praise I praise and when I'm negative
I'm very negative and I just need to
like really speak about the tied
commercials because they were pleased
they weren't incredibly awful and not
only did they have the audacity to have
such a bad commercial they had to
because they had a sequel after you left
did you watch yeah they had like I'll
get my studio later bring a new shirt
right so such a jump premise and not
only to be dumb once but to be jump
twice fool me once shame on you fool me
twice shame on you again that was ten
million dollars that they spent on those
two spots Plus like paying all the
agencies and you know I'm sure and the
celebrities Emily from Emily Hampshire
eek like I'm sure she had runs a high
fee yeah like what a waste of money
was interesting on the pre-show I think
they had like a side-by-side what it
costs to put a commercial in the first
Super Bowl it was seven eight thousand
dollars at last year it was this year
was 5.6 million dollars and then you
really have to think my favorite
commercial was smart puck by Hyundai and
that was five million dollars plus John
Krasinski Chris I forget Chris Evans
Chris Captain Mark captain america from
knives out Captain America
Rachel Dratch Chris Pine we had this
conversation
Chris Pine is Wonder Evan's Evan's
Evan's Rachel Dratch who I'm so glad
like got her moment she's a true star
and it was hilarious mama hilarious my
favorite was obviously Jason Momoa
rocket morgen rocket mortgage I'm
obviously gonna take out a rocket
mortgage now of course because that's
how much I just want to support this
fabulous brand it was it was so funny it
was so funny and you know like a
somewhat irrelevant brand like good for
them but you're talking about rocket
mortgage like Budweiser like those are
the obvious ones but rocket mortgage
really coming out I also really loved
the Amazon Alexa ones where then we
talked about Alexa through history with
Ellen with Ellen but it was just about
like I just thought it was so clever I
didn't really love I don't like when
people released their Superbowl
commercials before cuz I'm like not
surprised so I had seen that Alexa one
loved the Doritos lil NAS and the
mustache guy who sells him the Bradley
Cooper's brother
yeah what's our name Elliot yeah he's
very famous actor I'm sure we're
disgracing him in his entire career but
that was great too yeah torito's always
does a good job I just want to get a
major shout out to turbo tax for buying
a five million dollar spot and using the
same commercial they've been running
like on regular TV about how humans are
so amazing they can do anything except
pay their taxes it's true no but it's
like you're gonna spend all that money
you're not they're going to come up with
a new commercial yeah also I want to
talk about the Sabra commercial that was
like I was expecting to be my favorite
commercial just when I saw stills of it
Charlie D'Amelio
and Teresa and Caroline manager and star
that girl Britney who's amazing on
tik-tok who did the Kombucha thing you
was before your time on tick-tock
yeah yes she was in a two for one second
exact things also a tick talker they
spent so much money on talent to show
them for one second one second each I
was glad they brought Teresa and
Caroline together but I assumed the
premise was gonna be Sabra bringing
people together and then it's gonna be
like even Teresa
I can get going all these famous feuds
by the way free commercial idea it's so
much better yet and it was really
excited to see how somber is bringing
people together as opposed to how do you
you must musty-smelling it all happened
so fast I didn't even know what they
were showing us how everyone eats hummus
mas it was silly very silly
yeah always five million dollars and
then probably another five million
dollars on talent yeah but like I wonder
if you could pay people less for Super
Bowl commercials because there's it's
just like the happy I'm sure they're
happy to be there I think people are
willing to take a lot less money unless
you're like a mega superstar like I
thought the McDonald's commercial with
all the celebrities orders was fantastic
and like came out here just like making
money based off her name and likeness
without even getting out of bed
yeah well she had to probably get out of
bed like right time to conjure quarters
from McDonald's she texted it like I
thought it was such a cute premise me
shockula eats all the ketchup and Romeo
and Juliet chair milkshake very cute it
was just really cute McDonald's always
is just you know killing it like they're
not the best but they're up there no
they're the best it was it wasn't the
best but it was good snob pock was just
my favorite but it's so like I don't
want to be stupid but it might like it's
a high you need a commercial and why is
it why was it Boston just for fun I
think just for fun I think also a lot of
brands are very particular about not
taking a side in their commercials so
like that but Boston is like a totally
irrelevant City so I don't know why they
chose Boston but it was very funny maybe
all those celebrities were from Boston
oh yes she's nodding okay John Krasinski
Rachel Dratch and Chris Captain America
okay rules they left Ted out and that
hurts everyone sounded like Ted they
should have actually in order to really
make the point more clear that everyone
was from Boston they should have had
Mark Wahlberg yeah because I didn't even
realize that all those people were from
Boston yeah okay see I wasn't test yet
all in all though it was a really good
show like I have absolutely
jolly good show and maybe I know if he
was just so good because I was having
such a nice time at home like with the
food in the family sometimes like when I
sit watching a word show alone like all
I could do is hate on it because I just
be negative yeah but I don't think that
was it it was oh all the vibes it was
just the NFL 100 commercial we didn't
talk about oh my new one where they
started the ball yeah the commercial
bled into the live show it was that's
the stuff that was true on Genuity like
whatever creative agency came up with
that idea like it's like the NFL I'm
gonna give the perhaps to the NFL like
that
they're commercial for their show and
they used theirs all their talent it was
so great it was so funny when Jerry's in
the car and kids starts laughing over
his car
he's like Jerry Jones talked about like
Jerry from cheer it was just it was so
good the respective for Pat Tillman it
was it was a beautifully chilling but
also funny which is all you can ask for
everyone in our Super Bowl party was
just like up on their feet yeah at first
we were confused like where the kids
going
yeah like bring it to the house what's
the house and right it's like you know
what to do it's the game ball right and
then and then they came out it and they
made it live it was it was giving me a
grease alive vibes it was giving me like
chills it was beautiful it was truly
beautiful it was just a great show great
night for women great night for men as
well Demi Lovato was fantastic Demi
Lovato slayed perfection every note
there looked beautiful
like seemed so good she gave the moment
the utmost respect in that white
pantsuit she said I respect America and
with those vocals she said and I respect
our troops basically what you said back
to your time
yeah and these in writing that's the
Super Bowl it was spectacular it was
spectacular
and you know she had that tweet from 10
years ago where she said like one day
and I mean I could have told you that
she was a meant to sing the
star-spangled banner yeah um it's our
single yeah it's the star-spangled
banner and it was I was so happy for her
know that I am she's in such a good
place I'm so excited to see what she
does from here obviously we're in an era
of Demi Lovato yeah it's coming up and I
think it's fabulous I feel like last
night was like the culmination of a lot
of like months for her of like
transitional like transformative like
moments for her yeah this is her
launching pad okay so now I want to
predict who do you think is gonna do
this the halftime show next year it's so
hard to think because there's so many
people who are so popular but it's not
about popularity it's about longevity
like I don't think Billy Eilish could do
it you know I mean but the features are
about popularity yes you know so you
could throw in a Billy Eilish I don't
think she's there yet but I think no no
something else I think who's almost
there might be ariana grande I don't
think she's there people are begging for
well at least people I talk to are
begging for Taylor Swift but there's a
lot of controversy because she was the
face of Diet Coke for so long that I
think if
she can ever do it she'll have to wait
like 10 years even though her contract
is up it's like those things it's
stipulations in your contract yeah I
mean she that would be an amazing
halftime you know um you know that I did
predict this JLo halftime you did so
ready to give your official it's so hard
to know like what the NFL is looking for
it is and you know what we don't have a
lot in common in the NFL and I I feel
like you can really look to who's
getting residency's in Vegas we're not
gonna say Kelly Clarkson I mean that
would be such a great moment for America
she's NBC's you know dream girl yeah and
this Super Bowls on Fox but I don't
think it matters so I don't think it
does either but I just kind of mmm you
know that's a really good prediction and
I think she would bring in like a lot of
her friends maybe some of her voice
coach judges Oh dredges yeah yeah yeah I
think matter contestant that's right in
Kelly like I'm thinking about her but no
I'm no Shelton Elton John Legend that's
a very interesting prediction she's also
doing small residences in Vegas so which
we know because that that's interesting
and that's gonna mean my prediction
maybe not next year or maybe or five
years yes there's also here's who's in
Vegas Shania Twain did you own his
brothers well that's a little soon
Celine Dion but that's not the vibe like
vibe when I think back that to the fact
that Katy Perry did it I feel like that
was kind of early for her it was but her
show was spectacular and it was the best
halftime show I ever saw yeah agreed
I used to watch it over and over and
again at my desk at work yeah I thought
the Bruno Mars was excellent he's
perfect for he's been like mi a yeah I'm
sure he's working on his new album
because he was everywhere for so long I
said oh that's what happened yeah he
went on two tours over the same album
that's how great it was and that's how
like it got so big while he was on tour
that he had to redo it yeah I said like
I saw him twice yeah he's so good he's a
star um yeah it's exciting I just love
the Super Bowl I love that brings people
together United in in fighting brings
celebrities together it's just a great
culmination of everything in our culture
agreed and I thought last night was a
great a job well done
agreed cheers to the Chiefs and both
teams played great mhm
um and it's gonna boring we're like one
team's winning the whole time
yeah and they left it all out on the
field I would say and they gave it all
their heart you know and that's all we
can ask for the pliers yeah and I'm just
glad that we didn't look stupid for the
cheese just like when we went to the
Super Bowl a few years ago we were
rooting for the Patriots against the
Eagles and like Eagles fans steal DME
like Oh remember when we went in
Minnesota
yes Minnesota Minnesota okay well I do
think now it might be time do you think
I think so it's been like 30 minutes I
guess it's been 23 minutes oh my god
time flies when you're just recapping
creating content well it is time for the
fast five stories that you need to know
yes you before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast for sure
and I know we're in a bit of a pickle so
I'll just get right to it
today's episode is brought to you by sin
furred have you ever gone up to someone
and asked you smell amazing what perfume
you're wearing scent is the most
powerful sense you have a smell can
bring on a flood of memories influence
your mood and of course enhance your
natural style but while you're looking
for that signature scent that will make
you stand out and keep the memory of you
lingering your taste can be expensive
with scent bird you can have great taste
and mix up your fragrance routine
without breaking the bank
whether it's Tom Ford Gucci Versace sent
bird calm keeps you smelling good month
after month I have tried many cents from
cent bird and it's just the one thing
that really keeps me fragrant especially
you know it's a long day sometimes you
don't always have time to wash your hair
get a little spritz of Sanford in there
your good scent bird is a luxury
fragrance subscription service for
perfumes and colognes they've more than
600 designer brands for you to choose
from each month
choose the perfume you want to try and
they'll send you a 30-day trial not sure
what type of scent you're looking for is
sort and find your new fragrance by
brand style occasion season and more
plus they have products from other
categories like skincare wellness and
makeup they carry brands like Aparri
glam glow glow recipe tart and many
others and with our exclusive offer just
for our listeners you can get 30% off
your first month today that's only ten
dollars for your first fragrance go to
scent
bird comm slash Steen and use the promo
code Steen for 30% off your first month
that's scen t-bird dot-com slash Steen
to sign up and use the promo code Steen
to try your first perfume or cologne for
just ten dollars that's ste n San Juans
smell amazing
you love semper do you guys if you
haven't gotten on this imprint bad right
what are you doing what is you doing
okay first story really crazy but like
not that surprising but story
crazy Victoria's Secret exec ed Raziq
reportedly made life hellish for the
Angels models Victoria's Secret models
were constantly hounded by a creepy
executive who made unwanted sexual
advances and even once told supermodel
Bella Hadid that she had quote perfect
titties a court to it according to a New
York Times investigation the executive
IDI Raziq who we all know because he was
the one who did the Victoria Secret
Fashion Show very backwards man very
mean man and clearly like very
disgusting man I am shocked this is
shocking are you being for real no oh
okay well he stepped down from his from
its parent company Elle brands in August
but not before fostering quote an
entrenched culture of misogyny bullying
and harassment at the lingerie company
the paper found one model Andy Muse told
the paper that razzaq had harassed her
for months with intimate emails once
writing her quote I need someplace sexy
to take you Raziq would watch Hadid and
other models prepare for fashion shows
and remark out loud on their appearance
the report said so this has been a New
York Times report that came out a few
days ago that just goes like proof
receipts everything about what this guy
was doing at Victoria's Secret it's so
disgusting I'm so glad he's gone but
like damn he was in a position of power
for so many right and this is literally
like the least shocking thing ever and
it's like creepy to go back if you look
at all like the models who walked in
their instagrams like from that like
after the show they would always be like
Thank You ed razzaq like everyone was so
kissing his ass because he was obviously
such like a tyrant um I just really feel
like the brand can't bounce back from
this like they were already on the
downward and this article to me is just
like the nail in the coffin you think so
yeah I don't know brands like just
bounce back from this also he's gone so
everyone can just blame it on him right
we don't have a problem he was the
problem and he's gone
but it's cop knew about it we let him go
by the way when you when there's a
culture like that even if it's fostered
by one person like it is systemic so
it's like there's not just one person
like now he's gone we're better yeah
like she report one of the models had
like reported to HR right like nothing
happened right
so it's it's not just one person but
everyone blames and I'm on person and
then says problem solved and that's the
problem right the problem is that
there's still people who are just as
problematic I'm assuming as IDI razeq in
the company still yeah
not shocking not shocking but don't you
see it I'm glad justice is being served
me too
I just I've really had enough with this
company like I'm I'm good like I I've
had enough it's 20/20 like we can't I'm
done
yeah well check out the article for
yourself for all the deeply problematic
great titties like get the [ __ ] out of
here we're changing Edie okay next story
is just some positive news because
stormy we're sorry like sorry now that
we go back to this like why is like okay
it's a women's fashion show for women's
lingerie like why is a man in charge I
don't know and that's weird like if
they're getting changed like you
shouldn't be in the room but if it's
like a female you know in charge like
who get like it's just
why was he ever in charge I don't know
like what what expertise on lingerie yet
so it's like they're in women's
underwear there's one female NFL coach
you know but there's Edie Razik is in
charge of the women's fashion show like
it just makes no [ __ ] sense yeah no I
think the next NFL Commissioner should
be a woman I agree
even the scales okay totally stormy
world take two oh my god I saw Kylie
Jenner's daughter celebrates her second
birthday at an extravagant bash okay
extravagant it's just there's no word to
describe what stormy world to was I was
trying like ferociously just to
calculate all the expenses I'm dying to
know I
it has to have cost over a million
dollars a million right is it 1 million
dollars or five no because 1 million
dollars is like really incredibly well I
guess I can over-the-top beautiful like
wedding yes was like a [ __ ] theme
park so how much does it cost to build
Six Flags that's how much stormy world
[ __ ] I have to respect Kylie for
recycling some of last year's items
because at least she's not wasteful some
of the amusement park rides were the
same as last year so the blowup and
drains so that's called being frugal I
guess forgiving but I think I mean as
much as this was so crazy like not
normal
um a lot of it for Kylie like is
business like this is her business is
being like she just put up a strong
collection like you know it's just it's
all wrapped up I want to be surprised at
storming world as a tax write-off but if
storming world was also considered like
the official launch of the stormy
collection then I do believe she could
have put this expense on her business
yeah so I mean if you can do it she
looked so happy everyone was having so
much fun
Rosalia was there I'm like living for
the friendship I'm living for the
friendship there was a room that was
trolls me no store
loves trolls so also me thinks that
Kylie might have made some money on this
event because trolls like she was just
using the brand name like all the logos
like I don't think she had you know
expressed a copyright you know no that
but I think they love the fact that yeah
I Lee is pumping I think they actually
might have even paid her a little bit or
at least paid for that room yeah they
definitely send the mascots like yeah I
just wouldn't be surprised if like her
including frozen and trolls like is some
overall deal with Disney oh my god I
would be surprised I would because I do
things store me like loves trolls and
frozen and she is a woman of taste truly
um so we need to talk about SNL I was
just gonna say that the frozen sketch
from SNL this week was [ __ ] hilarious
and by the way that's exactly what I
said I said it on the show that the
storyline of frozen 2 was just like a
little confusing for campers like right
it was all over the place I'm 27 I
barely understood it I just love Kate
McKinnon I thought JJ Watt was great in
that skit and in the whole he's next off
he's Kristoff he's [ __ ] huge I just
I'm not to be annoying I was there
and JJ Watt it's first of all go to SNL
is very cool like everyone should go
wants to see how like the sauce is made
it's like true live television like it's
like old school like hairspray remember
and there's it's just so crazy how like
they literally go to a commercial break
put on full prosthetics change outfits
and come back and there was like a woman
whose job was to literally yank JJ Watt
the second his lines were done in a skit
get him changed and go to the other one
and when he would have run through the
studio like a the whole place shook I'm
like mark did you feel that she's like
yeah I'm like that was JJ Watt running
that's a [ __ ] huge and hot - he's so
hot he's so funny I thought he did a
great job Jim I thought the sketches he
was in like they were perfect for him
the Madden EA game hilarious was
hilarious a bachelor one was funny no
will they do this bachelor when every
year and it's like you guys are the
funniest people on the planet and you're
making the same jokes over and over like
I like their solo that make fun of with
the bachelor especially the suit I
didn't like and have they ever done the
same sketch twice why do they keep doing
it like this like yeah there's so much
there I thought it was strange it's it's
really weird yeah if someone could give
me an explanation like make some new
joke I have a lot of questions that I
love that I love that that's what Ari
said like yes I'm like why don't you
pick up on some new on system upgrade
it's not even relevant anymore and
another question I have about SNL while
we're asking questions what's up with
Pete Davidson like he was in the first
opening skit and then not at all yeah
that's just Pete Davidson I know it's so
strange we were really trying to like
shove Margo in his direction
Oh snitch Davidson yeah well Mitch and I
were there because we saw Luke Holmes
and by the way he was exceptional
I just so happy for him I hope he was
happy with his performance like it was
everything of the sort
it was everything of the sort um I've
actually been loving it wasn't always my
favorite song but I love loving or
loving on you and I er never broke my
heart like was the crown jewel of the
evening I wish he had done that first
but like I'm not Lorne Michaels I don't
make the rules yeah I think that they
always play like they're bigger Bob ii
keep people watching like the fans of
the artists but i thought i was so happy
for him i so happy to see him up there
he looked like he was having a good time
like the band members look like they
were having a great time and i
personally in my bed was having a great
time i personaly in studio was having an
amazing time me and Margo were sitting
right behind his parents they were so
cute and like so excited about that you
could tell it was his mom because she
had like bright red hair and they were
just so cute and it was so exciting and
me like way to them when he was done it
was really cute and it was just like a
great night for country music a great
night for comedy and a great night for
me I'm so happy for you yeah it was good
stuff it was cool everyone should go to
SNL like if you can like if you're a fan
it's cool to see like true live
television like that you just don't see
[ __ ] like that anymore like even if you
go to a taping of like Dancing with the
Stars like it's like I'm actually that
was like yeah I guess it's true yeah it
was cool really cool very cool
okay next story it's brought to you oh
by a very important brand that we have
to talk about because you pretty much
lit up the internet last week when you
wore your Rafi's guys I love my Roth E's
I wore them last night to the Super Bowl
I think you literally sold 1 million
pairs of Roth these when you wore them
on the show last let's make it 2 million
you guys I can't tell you how much I
[ __ ] love my Rafi's and I'm so
excited for it to be summer because
they'll go with like every summer yeah
they're so comfortable like every other
shoe gives me blisters and it's just so
sad but Rafi's are everything on the
sword they're everything of the Stork is
not only other comfortable they're
washable you can throw them in the
washing machine and they're sustainable
to the perfect everyday shoe for life on
the go they're comfortable and stylish
they go with everything from yoga pants
to dresses and skirts they come in an
ever-changing array of colors prints and
patterns and they're available in a
range of styles like sneakers loafers
points in a more you were wringing the
loaf
the loafers they launched new colors and
patterns every few weeks and they sell
out constantly
playful designs add fun pops of color
they can perk up any outfit while
looking polished and professional plus
they always come with free shipping and
returns and exchanges no risk no worries
no reason not to try plus they're
sustainable it'll blow your mind that
they're made from repurposed plastic
water bottles in fact they've diverted
over 35 million water bottles from
landfills already we love that another
major bonus is that they're fully
machine washable every time they need to
refresh you can simply toss them in the
washing machine that's such an
underrated thing like all shoes should
be machine washable you'll quickly
discover by buzzfeed call them there
forever shoe go-to Rafi's ro th ys comm
slash toast to get your new favorite
flats check out all the amazing styles
right now available at Rafi's dot-com
slash toast comfort style and
sustainability these are the shoes
you've been waiting for
head to Rafi's dot-com slash toast today
um actually just got a second pair of
frothy hmm I got them in white uh so
that I have my new spring shoe I can
spring into spring wait for spring
groundbreaking thank you
Thank You Miranda did it a floral pair
because for probably are quite
groundbreaking okay here's like some
exciting news Lady Gaga's new boyfriend
has been revealed as investor Michael
Polanski so this is not the studio
engineer that she was spotted with a few
months ago yes not okay the singer is
dating entrepreneur and investor Michael
Polanski a Harvard graduate who runs
Facebook co-founder Sean Parker's
groundbreaking Institute for cancer
immunotherapy Wow Wow very smart man she
has such a diverse um like interest in
men like she doesn't really have a type
if you look at like all the men she's
been with like they're so different no I
feel like she dates someone who doesn't
work out and she just like goes in the
opposite direction keep going for like
the same type of guy and making the same
mistake you know that's a good call if
she went from an actor to an agent to a
businessman beau right it does have to
tell you the business man beau is where
it's after these celebrities this might
be the end-all be-all for Lady gaga
because she now has a businessman beau
yeah like everyone's doing it everyone
you know and I'm gonna I'm gonna tell
you who started it really I think was
Miranda Kerr like she was so true she
was snapchat trans she made that Evan
her they're still married her name is
big nice life yeah they do and she like
just could stop working because she's
now mrs. beagle yeah so um I mean any
happiness for Lady gaga is happening
for all of them yeah I mean I do still
hold out hope that her and Taylor Kenny
will make it work even though like the
the further we get away from that
relationship I realize that's never
gonna happen but it's set it's said for
all of us who are just still like
holding out by the way they were spotted
together and Vegas over New Year's he
was oh yes I did see those pictures but
before that we had posted on her
Instagram she was out to lunch with a
cutie and they kissed but that was a
while ago so we never heard an update on
that I can he was just a fling yet maybe
it's a first date like you didn't work
out but I'm so happy for her
I love that it's it's hard to be I
imagine to be like a superstar and date
someone in the industry because it's
like there's definitely egos and
competition and I know I joined calm and
schedule okay so like I don't know and
and we've said on the show I always feel
like when when two major celebrities get
together and it does work out like one
of them always like kind of takes a step
back and I don't want that for Lady Gaga
so I think a businessman bow she's
definitely moving in the right direction
and I think she's getting close to
finding her forever yeah I only want
good things for her um me I mean same
sure such a I got distracted by the next
story but same and she was performing
she was there in Miami this weekend he
was there with her and she I think we're
gonna get lg6 soon yeah well she did her
Vegas residency show in Miami for like
an AT&T concert which I saw a few videos
of on Instagram looked like spectacular
I saw her residency it is if you're in
Vegas and I don't know if she's even
still doing them but they're amazing
these residences have gotten weird yeah
it's like a three-day residence and then
they'll come back in eight months and
it's like no they like do like more than
one show and call it a residency now ya
know or they'll do like a few weeks in a
row where it's like a residency is like
Donny and Marie right in Britney Spears
what was she there for 10 years yeah
Celine Dion yeah even JLo did like a
really weirdly short one and I thought
that was perfect for her like but now I
feel like she's not it's like I feel
like residency is almost like retirement
and I feel like she was gonna like
retire almost in Vegas but then
something happened and she like wanted
to keep working and I'm glad that she
did because she's bigger than ever I'm
glad that she did too because I'm after
we'll talk about in the next story it's
about Taylor Swift but she said
something in her documentary about how
like when a woman in the industry turns
like 35 she sends like an elephant
graveyard right and I just think like
JLo being 50 with her abs and the Super
Bowl on the stripper pole is just like
changing
everything yeah it's a testament to the
fact that that might not be true anymore
yeah or and you know the times were
changing they truly are
okay next story two stories it's a
doubleheader is about Taylor Swift okay
because her documentary sparking buzz
that she's engaged have you seen this
yes I mean I thought during the movie in
more than one scene she was wearing a
diamond ring on her left a ring finger
but like celebrities wear jewelry all
the time like I don't know if it's it
but it was the same ring yeah
and was it yeah I only saw at the one
time when she's sitting on the couch
here when she was in the car talking
about the eating disorder she was also
wearing it and it was a diamond it was a
rock yeah okay well then that's that
yeah and she basically said like I'm in
this great relationship and it's private
so like she's never gonna give us an
update so maybe this was the update
maybe but it's also like Kylie Jenner
wears a rock on her right finger all the
time and like she's either very much
married or single no but like when
you're rich and like you buy diamonds
like you only have so many fingers and
you're not gonna wear it on your thumb
so you live really or your pinkies you
live six options you have six options
and then like sometimes hands get
swollen yeah you know and I think I
wouldn't wear a big ring on my right on
my dominant hand so I would only wear it
on my left hand so I only have three
options now I can wear it on your
pointer
cuz I have two options yeah a middle
finger is nice it's just it's something
to think about
now you try to speculate or you know
fuel rumors but it's definitely an
interesting factoid that was worth
pointing out and she's gone out of her
way to make this relationship so private
that you know what I'm not gonna add
fuel to the fire but she seems happy and
that's it's all good
okay well their next story I think is a
really sweet full circle moment which
will lead into our recap of Miss
Americana Taylor Swift is responding to
Nikki Glaser's apology for calling the
singer too skinny this was fascinating
fascinating so in Miss Americana they
show clips of people in the press you
know talking about Taylor Swift's weight
and Nikki Glaser was one of those people
she was on a show she said something
that current her friends are so skinny
her and her model friends like it's
annoying they're just like too skinny
and she wrote Nikki laser then took to
Instagram to talk about how like she was
so embarrassed by seeing that hate her
caption it was really very sweet and
actually I do like follow Nikki Glaser a
little bit and I do know that she
actually really is like she wasn't just
like she's a big Taylor Swift fan so
this didn't seem to be coming from like
a thirsty or like dissing genuine play
I thought it was true truly genuine yeah
she said I love Taylor Swift
unfortunately I'm featured in her new
documentary as part of a montage of
asshat saying mean things about her
which is used to explain why she felt
the need to escape from the spotlight
for a year it's insanely ironic because
anyone who knows me knows I'm
obnoxiously obsessed with her and her
music I first heard myself from the
trailer last week as I watched it alone
in bed as soon as it came out because I
was so excited and I was horrified to
hear my own voice the sound bite was
from an interview I did five years ago
and I say in such a shitty tone quote
she's too skinny it bothers me all of
her model friends and it's just like
come on this quote should be used as an
example of projection in psych 101
textbooks if you're familiar with my
work at all you know I talk openly about
battling some kind of eating disorder
for the past 17 years I was probably
quote feeling fat that day I'm was
jealous also I've had people say the
same [ __ ] about me being too skinny
before and a know how terrible it feels
to hear that when you're struggling and
I was only bothered by her model friends
because I'm like I'd like to be her
friend and I'm not a model I really have
no need to post this other than to
apologize to someone who seriously means
so much to me
etc etc etc so I can only imagine the
pit in her stomach when she was just
like genuinely watching that documentary
trailer as a fan and ended up hearing
her own voice like that's a moment where
you literally just like [ __ ] your pants
no I totally agree but then Taylor
commented on Nikki's post saying wow I
appreciate this so much
one of the major themes of the doc is
that we have the ability to change our
opinions over time to grow to learn
about ourselves I'm so sorry to hear
that you've struggled with some of the
same things I've struggled with sending
a massive hug so this was just like a
great moment for women for Netflix like
for everyone I thought this was handled
so well on both sides like Taylor didn't
have to respond like I'm sure it's
excuse me in some ways like she probably
still holds a grudge to all the people
who said mean things about her because
like I would too so I thought that the
fact that she responded in any way was
shocking and the fact that she responded
like so courteously was just that's
Taylor yeah that is Taylor I loves that
and I just thought that whole story was
like crazy and by the the comments on
Nikki Glaser's Instagram she did
temporarily disable them because people
were being so [ __ ] me and it's like
if she didn't say anything like yeah
that's a lose-lose situation if
like you know dug her feet in it was
like it was a joke I'm a comedian like I
could do whatever I want but she very
easily could have done she just took
like the the the harder like to
apologize it's not easy and the comments
were just so mean at first like people
are so [ __ ] nasty yeah but I think
she said what she said and I'm sure she
felt like she had to get that off her
chest and like real people can recognize
real recognizes real you know I'm like I
would not be concerned with the comments
of people being green no and I just read
it like as a fan of both people and I
really felt like like she was so genuine
I don't feel like she wrote that post
for any other reason than the fact that
she actually felt bad yeah I didn't
think so it's not like anyone was
putting her on blast and she had to
respond you know write something she
wanted to say something yeah I watched a
trailer I didn't even realize that was
Nikki Glaser yeah so like it very easily
I'm sure she was getting like death
threats because the Swifty's or not but
I thought this was great I just really
appreciated all facets of it
um agreed okay let's talk about the
documentary okay we're gonna do our
recap of Miss Americana which is brought
to you by very appropriately third love
third love does brought differently they
believe that every woman deserves to
feel comfortable and confident everyday
with the right kind of support they help
her do this our bras are does that will
not are their bras are designed to fit
you not the other way around they're
designed with measurements from millions
of women their bra styles are made to
fit your life they have over 80 bra
sizes but we know that the only one that
matters is the one that's yours and I
switched to third love when they started
sponsoring the show and I don't think I
knew for the first 24 years of my life
what my real bra size was and that's
truly half the battle
they make bras that they believe in
every bra is backed by their perfect fit
promise which is 60 days to wash it and
wear it if you don't love it returns are
totally free every bridesmaid for your
comfort with memory foam cups and no
slip straps smooth scratch free brand
with a printed label a [ __ ] tag label
scratching your back is so annoying you
take their fit finder quiz over 15
million with million women have taken
the quiz to date it's super fun takes
less than a minute to complete and then
they help you identify your breast size
and shape and find the style that fits
your body their perfect fit promise has
every customer gives every customer 60
days to wash it wear it put it to the
test and if you don't love it third love
will return it for you and wash it
donate it to a woman in need so you
don't have to feel bad about that their
team of expert fit stylists are
dedicated to helping you find your
perfect fit it is cut hands-down the
most comfortable bra you'll ever own we
can attest to it they
that there's a perfect bra for everyone
so right now they were offering our
listeners 15% off your first order go
2/3 love.com / morning toast now to find
your perfect fitting bra and get 15% off
your first purchase
that's third love.com / morning toast
for 15% off today really great bra can't
recommend it that high on get your
titties at okay miss americano we saw in
theaters but did chemica mout on efflux
on friday but we saw it at i pick which
i thought seeing in theaters was so
premium like I don't know how I would
have felt if I watched it at home I just
loved being in the theater in the
theater was really like a toaster meetup
because it was 30 toasters in one room
it was really fun and everyone I'd like
to be in the theater like seeing the
reaction people were like clapping
singing agreed I got it is always fun
yeah I wonder how it a fella say if I
watch it at home did you watch it again
after no I need a few days but I will
watch it again yeah I thought it was
really great really well done really
enjoyable I love seeing the early
footage and like the rise you know and
like I think the like the 1989 I know
like it's interesting to hear her talk
about it and how you ever heard like she
was working so hard and like all the
accolades and she had everything it was
like the peak of her you know career it
was everything that she had worked for
yeah and everything that she had thought
that she wanted you know and she was
like so sinned and that was like what
she wanted what she wanted and then she
got it and and then she turned around
and she was just like what's the point
right and that was fascinating because
to me that's like my favorite era of
Taylor Swift and it like it sucks to
know that like it was not what she
wanted almost no but I think at the time
it was it was everything to her um but
then she just like took a step back and
and was like this is everything it's not
it's not every I'm alone right yeah um
but I just think that that era is just
even the red era - it's just so
sensational like the work that she was
doing she clearly worked so hard she had
she has this like chip on her shoulder
that was also funny Craig's in the
Superbowl you have a chip on each other
Lay's commercial it was like oh yeah it
was an insurance it was so it was I
thought it was like think about the
commercials it's Nicki making these
great funny sketches and they can't tie
it back to the brand sometime yeah these
commercials could be for any it's like
don't have a chip on your shoulder like
that sure oh my god I thought that was
so meet you but she does have a chip on
her shoulder literally she has this chip
on her shoulder where she feels the need
to prove herself over and over again
even though she's one of the greatest of
all time yeah
so I thought from like and I love the
footage of her putting a song together
and it's like in the audience we know
what the right words are totally and
watching her get there I think is so
interesting so I liked so many different
facets of the movie I thought like just
the rise to fame is so interesting like
an e true Hollywood story they had great
footage of everything I thought the
music making process was also really
interesting and she does those like
little vlogs when she was doing a
partnership with AT&T like the making of
getaway car and I loved those and this
was just like a longer version of that
and it's so exciting to know the final
product and watch her get their love
that I loved the personal stuff I think
my favorite part of the movie was Andrea
Swift Bing Crosby like she is hilarious
and I get why Taylor's just [ __ ]
obsessed with her like she's so funny
she's very smart she listens and
respects Taylor but it's also like an
authority figure and Taylor respects her
opinion there's there's so much respect
she's also a mom like I think a lot of
times the people's moms went especially
me to be sorry they try to just be your
best friend and or be your manager which
is weird right but like you still need
that that motherly figure and I think
they have a wonderful dynamic the big
dog on the plane was just hilarious
cause cancer dog like by the way any
like I cried during the movie so many
times like obviously during the sad
parts but then also just during random
parts where I just felt like I was
Taylor Swift and the whole saga about
her mom's health like makes me so sad
especially now we know in real time that
her mom is struggling again yeah so sad
so sad I love the seeing though like the
logistics of her life you know even like
the plane obviously the the cat backpack
which by the way you have to get four
Theo I know but he wouldn't like that
it's like special it's really only for
cats they're like sedentary Theo would
be trying to get out that's true I agree
logistics all the more is currently I
thought the same thing why did all the
cars have a curtain I guess because like
privacy is so like you really can't
trust anyone yeah no I mean it's not
like I just think it's another layer of
privacy that she she doesn't get privacy
anywhere if you didn't notice all the
like the Suburbans and the Escalade she
gets in to have a curtain behind the
drivers and passengers I've never been
in a car like that and I'm in existen
well remember that story that like when
she moved to New York she like hired
this car company and she got all of her
own cars and then she didn't end up
using it was like a whole drama but
she's obviously really specific about
her cars yeah well I understand you know
she can only control like so much and
then she drives a Toyota to her dad's
house oh I missed that yeah I couldn't
tell if that was like intentional just
like oh she's so humble or like she
actually drives a Toyota I mean
I don't know I miss it honestly it's
great for security no one's looking in
the Toyota for Taylor Swift it's true so
there were so many interesting factoids
honestly like I went to sleep right
after I watched it and then next day I
woke up I was like what did i watch
right um yeah what what else well the
politics of it all was just it's very
important and I am very vocal about how
I really don't like when pop culture and
politics
sit yeah interact because it's just it's
to me it's like people use pop culture
to escape politics and then it's like
you're infiltrating my safe place but I
actually understood why it was necessary
and I didn't mind it at all and I really
just was like feeling her journey like
when she was sitting on that couch and I
think like one of the dressing rooms at
one of her arenas explaining to her dad
and her manager while like she why she
felt it was necessary and he was like
that was when the Bing Crosby thing
happens which was so funny I she was
like crying about how like March of
Blackburn's out here saying that this is
like good Tennessee Christian values and
she's like I'm from Tennessee and I'm
Christian and she was crying and I just
don't know how anyone could say that
like she's so calculated and like
strategic when that was just such a
natural genuine moment oh for sure but I
think people are saying she's
calculating shorty chick not even about
her foray into politics just about her
career and how she lives her life right
and then when she was in the beginning
of the movie got all choked up sitting
on the couch about how like people's
opinions of her like affect her so much
when people say she's just so calculated
when it's like when you have a career
you plan things out like that's not
being calculated that's just being
strategic like and when she got all
choked up on the couches talking about
how sometimes it gets so loud that like
you can't ignore it like I just I
empathize like I just love her so much
I just this movie was just great for me
like seeing her with her ponytail and
with her bangs and I just feel like her
bangs are so important like they're just
I'm glad that she like really believes
in the bangs yeah I think it was it was
great cuz it helped me understand at I
like her experience like mostly like the
1989 era and then you know going into
hiding and like how hard that must have
been for her but I was talking about it
with my friend and then she said
something that made me realize that
that's how I feel about it's like this
movie didn't change how I feel about
Taylor Swift in any way know me to it
cuz I still love her yeah ya know and I
still I love her music I like her a lot
um but like there's just something I
took a car home with Olivia
from the movie and she's just like so
[ __ ] negative I literally was like
wanting to kill her like opening my
window gonna stick my head out just so
she would stop talking like because
she's and she said this and she said
that I'm like Aaliyah just shut the [ __ ]
up like I just couldn't deal with her
I'm like let me read the room I don't
want to listen to you there was times
when I was watching the movie where the
documentary was like overwhelmed chills
I was like wow I'm here for you and
there were other times where I was
rolling my eyes a few times but I still
overall like but I thought it was great
yeah I thought it and we never get
insight into her life and as I feel like
as she's growing up and like realizing
what's important to her she's gonna
become more and more private until she's
really just like the music doing what
she wants and even with like her touring
you know love her fest is reppin from
like what she did for reputation I
thought the utilization of her music was
so cool like how I cannot believe that
they use nineteen eighty nine out of the
woods tour version like to me that is
her best and worst song like when I
heard on the radio I'm like damn this is
my least favorite song and then when she
redid her own song like into a different
version on tour like I'm like oh this is
the best song she's ever written and the
fact that they used that and I and I get
what they were saying that was that was
1989 when she was just trying to prove
to everyone like her songs work out her
vocals work out her dancing was good her
outfit was got her body was good and
she's at the Grammys working so hard in
that sequin jumpsuit trying to hit that
high note like I totally got it and then
they used clean when she performed clean
at reputation which was about her her
sexual-assault which was oh my god
chilling like I just we we literally
have no choice here
yeah also it was raining when she's
saying clean and like that was so
perfect perfect it was just a great
moment she loves a range show she does
um and I just want to say like I think
we've said this on the show but I do
think reputation like is masterpiece
I think it's before its time and I think
that I remember she was nominated for
Best Pop Vocal out she was already
nominate for that an ariana grande one
for sweet nur and I just have to say
like that was the wrong choice I thought
it was interesting that they included
the phone call where she found out she
can get nominated for a Grammy because I
think amongst the Swifties they're like
she doesn't do it for the awards like
she does it for the fans and she does do
it for the fans but I think she cares a
lot about getting the respect of the
Grammys and I feel like that scene
confirmed for me that like she really
does care about that stuff like who
wouldn't and she's like the time I'll
make a better one I'll make a bet it was
really it was very sad and that was
about reputation right yeah so then she
did make a better one or she made one
love her and that also didn't get
nominated
any of the four categories like the
Grammys are just done with her yeah we
like she had her time album of the year
twice because really like when I look
back on the year the album of this year
there one at least one of them is lover
and it wasn't even nominee it's weird
you know so like it's they're just done
and and it's very well done like you
can't say it we didn't get nominated cuz
it's bad you know phenomena I'm like
reputation was phenomenal but it was a
little weird it was different it was
different and it was it like you know it
was darker it was a huge shift for her
so like her not getting nominated I
could see how someone would be like well
that wasn't for me yeah but like lover
is everything of the sort and it's the
it really was like the best album like
an illusion of at least been like Billie
Eilish still should have won but it
should have been nominated amongst the
albums of the year because it was an
album album of the year and then you
have to factor in numbers and her album
like outsold every album that was
nominated so that has to be a factor
like what the people
like has to matter yeah not just what a
few old people in a building thing but I
mean I think the Grammy every artist has
that complaint I think the Grammys this
year like actually did a pretty good job
yeah of highlighting what the people
like not everyone can be a winner this
forty-niners I'm sorry it just wasn't
your time and yeah and I mean but then
it's like she said she won her second
album of the year that's all she ever
wanted and it wasn't even what she
wanted so like sometimes when you put
all your eggs in yes it like you have to
look at the other basket yeah I think if
you're a Taylor Swift hater or Taylor
Swift lover you should just watch the
documentary because it is fascinating
and if you're a Taylor Swift fencer um
you're gonna stay on the fence and yeah
I think that's fine it was it was great
and I just I need Andrea Swift so like
is there a 1989 tour I can watch yes of
course it's on Apple it was a
partnership with Apple and it's one of
my least favorite of her tours because
whoever edited it was obviously like on
adderall because they change the screen
like she's singing a song they'll go
close up back up audience so fast like
you could have a seizure watching it
like hey and I thought that I was like
just being like picky when I didn't when
I watch it for the first time I was like
where is she like and amongst the
Swifties people are like what the hell
was going on when they edited this talk
this tour which is upsetting because it
is my favorite tour but they were
they're so nuts whoever edited it like
choppy choppy chop chop chop chop
but it's it's the
okay interesting and very upset is that
we never got a red tour because it was
filmed by Terry Richardson uh and then
right after he filmed it all like the
weirdness about him came out he still
works yeah but she doesn't want to make
any money like for him so it was never
released what about the fence I know
buy it from him like for whatever yeah
right I think like outright I think he
has money like I know you don't want to
give me more but I think this speak now
tour which we actually which was
responsible for like my stand hood of
Taylor Swift because one time I was at
Radio Shack like running an errand and
when I was checking out they had this
DVD like sitting at the front cashier
and I just grabbed it and it happened to
me the Speak Now tour DVD that I watched
1 million times it's a great one to and
you could see like how she became such a
superstar totally yeah it was really
good it was really good what else oh I
watch them I was telling you guys I
watch this new show this weekend doll
face on Hulu on Hulu it's just like
quick and short and is really cute and I
watch it it reminds me of well they also
have a few of the same cast members it's
like crazy ex-girlfriend like it's kind
of a weird show and Ricki but I enjoyed
it and I'm gonna watch that and shrill
new season of shrill oh yeah you know
what I watched the first episode and it
was horrible just because the first
episode was like the end of the same day
is the last episode of the first
oh man it was just like no one had
showered like no they didn't brush their
teeth and it was just like grossing me
out
and then I was just like I'm mad I'll
finish it because I love her but it was
just like it was this whatever happens
in the second episode that's how the
series the season could have started
right no I don't like when they pick up
right like the same moment because also
I forget yeah okay we do have a fifth
and final story oh my god I thought that
was it I know I should have worked nice
it a little differently but um Halsey
goes ballistic on a heckler shouting GE
Z's name at a pre Superbowl performance
did you see this video I saw it oh my
god she is amazing [ __ ] love her same
people are so [ __ ] annoying yes so
someone she was like talking in the
middle of her said it was kind of like a
small she kept calling it a club so I
guess was a club like an intimate venue
yeah and this guy was or girl I don't
know was shouting gez from the audience
and she just turned around and lit them
up she was like shut the [ __ ] up I'm
gonna throw you the [ __ ] out of here
stop [ __ ] shouting gez like come on
what are you doing what are you doing
and it's like if you're
a loser like to go to an intimate affair
for Halsey like you those those are hard
to get tickets to it's not like you
could just waltz in and like it it was a
small venue really for her fans like
what are you doing you loser like
spending your time and money getting to
a place just so you could heckle someone
yeah
loser loser I'm so glad I never ever had
a baby with you same
okay well that now that was a short
story but in interesting the video is
chilling I suggest everyone search on
Twitter like I love her I really like
I'm turning into what every day number
is something that just makes me like
understand that why she's such a big
sensation right and why she has like
that cult following she really does yeah
okay is that it I think that's it feels
asleep like we're dead like that really
was what times we talked about so much
stuff what time is it it's 11:30 um
that's not that long like an average oh
yeah but we talked about like a ton of
stuff covered mmmm Super Bowl No
thank you so much for listening to the
morning toast the millennium morning
show where we go live Monday to Friday
10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on you YouTube
so where ever you know sorry I [ __ ]
that up okay take it from the top
thank you so much for watching the
morning toast the Millennial morning
show where we go live Monday through
Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on
YouTube so if you're watching us on
YouTube please subscribe leave a comment
you know get involved like this video
we're also available as a podcast pretty
much anywhere podcasts can be found so
that's Spotify iTunes stitcher Public
Radio I our videocast box wherever you
choose to listen to podcasts find us the
morning toast leave a five star review
about how beautiful stunning and smart
we are we love you guys so much have an
amazing day we will see you tomorrow